all right hi everybody
got a special announcement today
[Laughter]
welcome welcome to the stream welcome
all right so you know uh
let me tell you guys a story uh the year
was 1776
and the richest man in america george
washington
was upset that some guy in some far away
land
was trying to charge him tax this is a
true story he's the richest man in
america so
he got his other billionaire buddies
together they recruited
an army told them they were fighting for
freedom and independence
and they fought off a bunch of idiots
who dressed up in bright red uniforms
they were called the hessians
and they were german mercenaries and
they were bright red uniforms and they
were idiots
uh they lost some dudes from american
dudes you know hardcore freedom-loving
american dudes with like ar-15s hanging
out in the woods
you know taking out the hessians one at
a time and the hessian's like
marched in a bright red uniform
secession which you know in retrospect
is like kind of stupid
and it makes you wonder about people
back then but none of this has anything
to do with the story except that
uh two days from now is july 4th sunday
so hopefully you guys are going to you
know watch fireworks
uh you know eat grill grill with hot
dogs and hamburgers
uh let me just post a stream on discord
and then we'll get to what the
big reveal is um oh wow the stream
already has the reveal
oh it's in the front it's in the logo
guys hi so for the first time in common
history
uh we're not giving you guys a sale
we're doing something
even better we're offering you something
so exclusive that it's never been
offered in
all of common history despite it
actually being really easy to make
for us super hard for you alright this
is a comma two notice the color it comes
in
black just like the model t
this weekend only we're offering the
color drop down
patriot edition made in america
red with a white border guaranteed white
border gonna be a blue phone but those
are two rare and exclusive
blue coming next year this is this year
the
2021 patriot edition in red
red red okay so this one is in black
this one is in red
okay so if you want to buy one of these
um
we thought about making the price you
know we're like ah
what should we make the price and you
know i suggested 1776
but nope it's actually just 10.99 it's
the same price
um we made five of these so hopefully
five of you buy them
if more than five people buy them we're
gonna make even more
as many people want to be a patriot as
want can
purchase the comma 2 patriot edition
it's red that's all i have for today's
stream i'm not going on forever with
these streams anymore
you could wear a cool hat like this you
could drive around in your lifted truck
with your red patriot edition i think
someone supports the dodge ram
uh you can also drive around in your
prius because you know that's part of
america too
that's right california is still part of
america um
i drive around your prius with your red
comet 2 that you can buy
only this weekend seriously never again
i'm never doing this again
like this is your only chance to get
this exclusive red comic 2 now
one caveat on the red combo 2 is if you
do send them in for
warranty repair you're going to get a
black one back
so you know the red is ultra rare ultra
exclusive you could buy yours today and
now we're going to add everyone on
discord to tell them this all right
bye-bye
patriot edition bread